có phía lạnh anh hợp đến tạy tình thông phay là chụt tình sự hiện.
Thật tổng kê thì bảo tăng sau trong 4 năm qua, đạy xả 2 lắm đời chụp tí lạnh.
Tuy nhiên, tình tình xuất xuất hiện từ nhiều năm về chụp.
Đà chú ý là từ năm 2018, đến năm 2018,
tình thông xuất hiện trong tăng sau.
Như vậy, là có thể thấy theo sự biến đổi của tí hậu thì mẹ tổ chái đất ởm lên.
Về xuất hiện các lời chụp tí lạnh anh hợp đến tà trong tăng sau của tình thần.
Về giết biến của đật công phía lại này thì giữ báo dòa,
và phụ công phía lại và mưa.
Khi nổ thức nhất trong đật công phía lại này ở khu vực đông bất bộ của tình hóa,
phụ biến từ 2019, 2019,
một nguy bắt bộ có nơi dế hành mô độ.
Mức dịch cao nhất trong này sẽ thật nhất dưới bà mì mô độ.
Đà chú ý là từ chiều và đêm nay đến 2019,
và bắt bộ sẽ xuất hiện một tật mưa tò trên dịch dật.
Trong đó, khu vực tình thấy bắt bộ, phía bắt của phủ thỏ và tình cuảng thì có mưa tò trên đến dịch dịch dịch dịch.
Và giống cạnh báo, mình cần bước có cổ cưởng độ lưỡn trên một trong biến mát,
giữn dà trong khu vực bà giật.
Trong bước giống, thì cần hết sức liệu ý tới hình tượng tổ lấp,
mưa đả và an sửa xếp mạnh.
Ở câu thí phía tại các bộ phía mắt của tình thó và tình cuảng,
cần đêm phòng, với hình tượng lũ quayc của biểu chật là đất.